I would say param Lana to be openly gay
um you know my friends know I didn't
have you for anyone I've not had a
conversation with hands about it's all
my family I say I guess I've had my
siblings but it's it's basically a dude
hospital situation with me you know in
Kenya homosexuality is illegal under the
Penal Code those who have found guilty
of engaging in gay sex can be sentenced
for up to 14 years in prison this means
many like Noah live in constant fear the
National Gay and Lesbian Human Rights
Commission has responded to at least
1700 cases of abuse or mistreatment
we're talking about the right to not
experience violence simply because you
identify as lesbian gay or bisexual so
one thing that we reiterate over and
over is that this case is not about
same-sex marriage this case is not about
non-consensual sex this case is not
about sex with minors this case is quite
simply about what two adults are allowed
to do consensually in the privacy of
their home without governmental
interference in Noah's view it's time
for Kenya's high court to repeal the
colonial era law relation homosexuality
would be a great start because it's a
clitoris in a position where we're no
longer targeted because you know you
find a lot of people who are targeted in
the sense that police are you know
people collaboration police to arrest
you and then bribe you as family or
threaten you you know blackmail you and
so it will remove it'll take away that
power from these people on the streets
of Nairobi it's hard to find someone who
openly agrees with Noah I feel they are
they are ungodly they there again is
human morals and I think they should not
be allowed in Kenya
I don't think it's okay yeah I think it
should be talked about
yeah something it's not something that
should be ignored yeah that's that's
that's not right according to their
Bible according to all religions it
should not be allowed in an interview
just this year president who who cannot
has said that homosexuality was not a
human rights issue in Kenya this is not
the first time president who can yata is
dismissing the issue of homosexuality in
Kenya as a priority discussion in 2015
during former US President Barack Obama
state visit he almost said the same
thing however the reality is there is a
significant population that needs this
discussion to be had even if the High
Court rules that the law should remain
in place the fight to sensitize Kenyans
on the issue of gay rights will continue
so we're not at a place where I think
we're able to convince 99% of Kenyans
that this is something they need to
accept but what we need to be able to do
is have laws that say these people are
protected and then have the people
responsible for enforcing those laws be
able to do that Nowell hopes the court
will repeal the law so that he can live
a life where he doesn't have to
constantly look over his shoulder